we are following major developments in
the growing political crisis in
Venezuela its president severed
diplomatic relations with the US after
President Trump backed an opposition
leader who's claimed the presidency the
standoff comes amid rising violence
seven people were killed yesterday
during massive protests demanding
president Nicolas Maduro stepped down
security forces used tear gas and water
cannons against the demonstrators major
Garrett is that the White House was more
on this developing story major good
morning to you good morning it has long
been a priority of this White House and
bipartisan voices in Congress to
pressure Venezuelan president Nicolas
Maduro to step down now the White House
has formally backed opposition leader
Juan Y doe now bloodshed and violence
repression already exists in Venezuela
but this move carries the risk of still
more now sources tell CBS News guido
swore himself in as interim president
yesterday and is now in hiding in the
capital city of Caracas the 35 year old
Guido his head of the National Assembly
regarded by most international observers
as the last remaining democratic
institution in the country the US and
most world powers see Maduro as a
dictator in regard his recent
re-election nothing more than a sham to
ramp up pressure of the administration
is considering sanctioning Venezuela's
lucrative oil exports Maduro still has
major backers on the world stage namely
China and Russia it is unclear how deep
his support rungs among Venezuelans
military or Federal Police Venezuela is
in the midst of a massive humanitarian
crisis the worst by far in the
hemisphere food and medicine are scarce
and violence on the streets
ramp it now Maduro says the US has 72
hours to remove its embassy personnel
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo said
because the United States does not
recognize Maduro as legitimate that
order will be ignored the president said
in 2017 2018 and again yesterday all
options are on the table to support the
opposition John all right major thank
you
some one fact inflation in Venezuela up
1 million percent money paper just a
huge story you
we'll continue covering